we begin with our top story a scary end
to 2023 at the southern border more than
286,000 migrant Encounters this month
shattering the previous record high from
just a few months ago add on at least
83,500 known Goda ways since October 1st
Texas is about to enforce a new law
giving its police the power to arrest
migrants who illegally cross into our
country those illegals will have their
choice to either return to Mexico or
serve up to 6 months in jail and
possibly longer for repeat offenders the
the justice department is now telling
Texas don't enforce your law or we'll
see you in court Texas's top prosecutor
Attorney General Ken Paxton he joins us
now Mr attorney general thanks so much
for joining us on Sunday morning Futures
uh the Department of Justice they don't
like what Texas is doing they say they
don't need any help they don't want your
help and if you try to offer it to them
and do it they're going to sue you
what's your response yeah it's pretty
crazy to see what's happened over the
last three years of the bid
Administration those numbers as you've
seen get worse not better it's not like
they're solving the problem they're
actually helping Aid and ab bet the
cartels and then Texas says we've had
enough we're going to do something about
it and then they threaten us from
enforcing our own laws it seems pretty
crazy and it's hard to believe that we
have a a government that is working
against its own citizens and helping the
cartels move as many people across the
border as
possible you know the the the the amount
of drugs the human trafficking the toll
that it's taking the housing stress that
is put on there you know if you if you
were to listen to the mayors of Chicago
New York and other cities they blame
Texas for shipping all of these migrants
up into their states and having it
become their problem they tend to forget
that you know the federal government was
shipping them there and putting putting
them on airplanes to get them there uh
but what's your response to
that well look all of these cities
during the Trump Administration created
Sanctuary cities and and dis and
discouraged the Trump Administration
from blocking the border and keeping
these illegals from coming across now
that the Biden Administration is
allowing them and they're they're
getting a few hundred or a few thousand
versus the literally hundreds of
thousands if not millions that the
border states are getting they're
complaining and it's it's a little
ironic that they're so they're BL Texas
when all we're dealing with is a much
more significant problem than they
are explain to us the gravity of the
problem and the challenge that you're
having to deal with there in Texas I
mean it's hard to Fathom how big a
problem that might
be you know what it's costing us
billions of dollars but that that's not
the most significant thing the most
significant thing is the crime the the
the increased human trafficking drug
trafficking we have literally thousands
of kids dying from fentanyl overdoses
that don't have to die because we have
the cartels having an easy line into
Texas and and an easy line to get into
the country and so it is having a
significant impact and it is going to
spread Beyond Texas beyond the border
states it is an American problem and I I
I think it's clearly caused by the Biden
Administration you can see that under
Trump these problems were were
diminishing and now under the Biden
Administration who has basically struck
down all the policies that worked we
have significant problems with all of
these things and they're getting worse
every day which is hard to believe you'd
think after 3 years he would have
figured out a way to make it better in
in instead it's getting
worse well you know there's an
immigration backlog in the courts there
of some three million people some of
these people coming across the border
are getting court dates that are 10
years in advance at least that's what
some of the reports are saying so I
don't know how they proposed to do this
but you know they sent secretary Marcus
and secretary blinkin down to meet with
the Mexican president but that seemed to
be a meeting to just have a meeting and
now they're talking about actually
actual amnesty what's your take on
what's going on there yeah look this is
a joke there's so many people coming
across there so many people in the legal
system there's no way they'll keep up
with it but everybody knows how it
actually works they come in they claim
Asylum there's under Trump they would
had to stay outside of the country under
Biden they're allowed in they disappear
most of them don't show up for their
hearings and and there's almost no
expect that they will given the numbers
and given the backlog it's not realistic
to think that many of these people or
most of these people are ever going to
actually have their hearing they're here
to stay and that's and the Biden
Administration knows that they they
built the system to make it happen and
this idea that somehow these meetings
with Mexico where Mexico is now
requesting that as as a fair trade for
them stopping the the illegal
immigration through their country into
ours that we're going to somehow fund uh
dictators in South America and Central
America I mean what could go wrong with
that it just seems like a really bad
idea and we've lost our leverage given
the fact that the Biden Administration
doesn't enforce Our Own federal
immigration
laws well and now we're getting reports
that there's some 15,000 people in a
caravan moving up and north and look
these are like daily numbers now coming
out of out of uh Mexico not all not all
Mexicans people from all across the
world we have no idea who who these
people are and where they what they're
trying to do so I Texas I I feel for you
because you're trying to do something
and yet the Department of Justice wants
to sue you over it rather than ask for
your help well not only that but you
know they're cutting down our fences
they're cutting down our wire we suit
them over that I mean they won't even
let us like put up fences they they they
they damage our property come out of our
property and then of course this this
threat of a lawsuit because we merely
want to protect our own citizens from
the crime and the cost of illegal
immigration when it's really their job
to do it and instead we've got the Biden
Administration as I said aiding and ab
betting the cartels encouraging the
cartels to make billions of dollars and
to bring as many people here as POS as
fast as possible and as soon as possible
that's what the Biden Administration is
doing they're not just not doing their
job they're actually encourage
encouraging the
opposite well it's interesting to me
when they went down and met with the
Mexican president made me wonder are you
meeting with the right people because
it's strikes me that the drug cartels
the mafia if you will is actually more
in control of the northern part of the
Mexican border than the than the Mexican
Government and they they could put
troops up there they could do things but
I just really wonder who's actually
controlled there in northern
Mexico well I think you're right I mean
there's no doubt that the Mexican
Government could do more to help us and
they and they did under the Trump
administration because president Trump
insisted on it but there is no doubt
that the cartels have been incentivized
they're making billions of dollars they
make you know8 to 12,000 a person that
they bring so they're incentivized to
bring as many people as possible and
remember it used to be the way border
patrol worked they were there to stop
people from coming across the border and
now the cartel doesn't try to hide
people they don't try to sneak people
across they take them directly to border
patrol it's like a handoff so it's a
partnership it's not it's not the way it
was supposed to be but that's where the
Biden Administration has taken us
they've taken us to a partnership with
the cartel so the part cartels have the
opportunity not only to make as much
money with importation of humans but
also the border now is clear for their
trafficking of drugs and other things
that they make money off of and so
they're building this network not just
in Mexico but across the across the
country unbelievable I appreciate what
Texas is trying to do Texas Attorney
General Ken Paxton happy New Year thank
you for joining us I'm Steve Ducey I'm
Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart and
click here to Subs subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis